la integración es el área debajo de cada
señal y nos dice el número de protones
en esta señal aquí tenemos el espectro
de rm n del protón de acetato de vencido
incluyendo los valores de integración la
computadora calcula el área debajo de la
señal por ejemplo para esta señal el
área bajo esa señal es calculada por la
computadora y nos da este número la
computadora nos da 57.9 para esta señal
la computadora nos da como resultado
23.1 y finalmente para esta señal
obtenemos un valor de integración de
35.4 volvamos aquí arriba a la
estructura de puntos del acetato de
bencilo y veamos cuántos protones
tenemos que tomar en cuenta para nuestro
espectro de rm n de protón este carbono
de aquí tiene 3 protones déjame
continuar incluyendo esos
pero toni
este carbono tiene dos protones en él
y hasta ahí llevamos 5 y luego en
nuestro anillo tenemos 5 protones
yendo alrededor del anillo aquí tenemos
5 más para un total de
así que tenemos que tomar en cuenta 10
protones en nuestro espectro
volviendo a los valores de integración
encuentran los valores de integración
más pequeños de esos tres números 23.1
es el valor de integración más pequeño y
vamos a dividir los tres valores de
integración entre el más pequeño y
empezaremos con 57.9 tenemos 57.9
dividido entre 23.1 usemos la
calculadora aquí 57.9 divide eso entre
23.1 y obtenemos 2.5 escribiré 2.5 aquí
23.11 / / 23.1 obviamente es igual a 1 y
luego finalmente 35.4 dividimos eso
entre el valor de integración más
pequeño 35.4 dividido
/ 23.1 nos da un valor cercano a 1.5
tenemos 1.5 aquí y eso nos da una
proporción de los protones que están
dando estas tres señales la proporción
sería 2.5 a 1 a 1.5 pero no puedes tener
2.5 protones no puedes tener medio
protón y entonces esos no son los
números exactos de protones cierto
necesitamos tomar en cuenta a 10
protones en nuestra molécula y si
piensas en ello si multiplicas estos
números por 2 nos da lo que queremos
porque si multiplicas 2.5 por 2 eso nos
da 5 si multiplicas 1 por 2 eso nos da 2
si multiplicas 1.5 por 2 eso nos da 3
y obviamente 523 nos da 10 y 10 protones
son el número de protones que tenemos
que tomar en cuenta para nuestra
molécula entonces esta señal justo aquí
corresponde a 5 protones esta señal
corresponde a 2 protones y esta señal
corresponde a 3 protones si volvemos
aquí arriba a nuestro diagrama de puntos
y vemos esos protones así que tenemos 3
protones equivalentes el desplazamiento
químico para estos protones junto al
carbón y lo esperaríamos que el
desplazamiento químico sea apenas
pasando 2 y eso es por supuesto lo que
vemos aquí el desplazamiento es apenas
pasando 2 esta señal representa a 3
protones y son estos 3 protones de aquí
luego veamos estos dos protones estos
dos protones están junto al oxígeno el
oxígeno los deslinda y estos dos
protones también están cerca a este
anillo de benceno de aquí
si esperamos un desplazamiento químico
más alto y tenemos dos protones que por
supuesto tienen esta señal
la cual corresponde a dos protones
finalmente tenemos cinco protones casi
equivalentes en nuestro anillo podría no
ser exactamente iguales pero para la
señal aquí tenemos cinco protones
dándonos esta señal y es un poco más
compleja que las otras pero mira dónde
está estás en una región aromática en
términos de desplazamiento químico por
lo que esta señal debe de representar
estos cinco protones aromáticos en
nuestro anillo y entonces esto te
muestra lo útiles que son los valores de
integración te dicen te dicen cuántos
protones y están dando esa señal que te
permite saber la estructura de la
molécula